let's talk regrets do you have many I
have regrets with regards to your regret
do you have any similar regrets a lot of
the other regrets would probably shape
me differently today do you have a lot
of regrets nope why do you think that is
because I'm real what about you makes
you real I don't know because uh I'm as
real as it gets if this regret were no
longer a regret how would it change your
interaction with your family I think
they would have seen me as the true
person that I am how do you think your
friends would be any different with you
I think of my friends we would have a
lot more in common what are some things
about this regret that made you think
about sharing this story I actually
don't have that many regrets you said it
would make a difference to your career
do you travel a lot I would say I travel
more now than in previous years how
would your friends treat you differently
if you regret were not your regrets I
think I will have different types of
friends what would be different about
them I don't know I'd never Wonder